[Musik]
130 tonnen schwer 32 meter lang drei
meter sechzig breit die farbe mit teilen
einer windkraftanlage auf der autobahn
diese gigant ist fast nur nachts
unterwegs seit 20 jahren macht er zerrt
unwahrscheinlich eine armee mit
aber da muss ich noch ein paar jahre
machen objekt haushalte irgendwie sind
nicht
[Musik]
am ende der nacht beginnt die
schwierigste operation einfahrt der
schwerlaster auf die baustelle eng
schlecht befestigt alles dunkel an einer
kreuzung weiß keiner mehr wo es langgeht
ich muss das stück zurückfahren damit
haben wir haben entscheidet sich für die
rechte zufahrt sein begleiter ist den
urlaub die aushilfskraft gibt grünes
licht ein folgenschwerer irrtum hardy
bleibt hängen
[Applaus]
den pokal hoch mehrere versuche
scheitern keiner weiß warum artikuliert
es immer wieder er kommt nicht vom fleck
die nerven liegen blank keine antwort
100 leute
die ganze kolonne aufgehalten
der ersatz begleiter ist nervös jetzt
erst erkennt was los ist ich schwere
last hat sich im tiefen boden verhakt
wie stehst du schon sagst du dann mal
off liegt die punkt den aufleger nach
oben bis zum anschlag
so löst sich die achse ausgebildet ist
immer noch sauer
hardy ist bedient so ein ärger 15
stunden
ich war jetzt feierabend
ich lasse sie soeben war morgen früh
wenn sie mich rufen wieder runter
frequenz den ernsten weg wieder runter
fahren muss und da ist die sache durch
ich meine jetzt feiere haben die können
wir alle haare stecken
köln eine handvoll trucker mit ihren
familien demonstrieren für die
einhaltung des mindestlohnes kollegin
aus osteuropa machen den markt kaputt
fahren für dumpingpreise erich ist in
rente wohl trotzdem mittendrin
[Musik]
man muss die zukunft von der junge und
deswegen wollen wir die junge
unterstützen damit diese wieder eine
zukunft haben
für alle dinge eine bezahlte zukunft
kundgebung auf dem domplatz die trucker
beschlagen immer härteren bedingungen in
der branche viele fuhrunternehmer
ignorieren pflicht pausen und lenkzeit
vorschriften aber wer hört schon auf
drei dutzend trucker die fahrer kein
thema die zeigen kein zusammenhalt sieht
man ja hier an der spärlichen teilnahme
wenn ich mir vorstelle dass eine million
lkw und wuchs in deutschland und das
häufchen elend hier betrachten
[Musik]
am rande der kundgebung haben sich
morgens um zehn touristen zum
frühschoppen niedergelassen
sie haben so gar nichts übrig für die
sorgen der fernfahrer und setze mich
daher die schon woanders hingehen wir
wollten ein ganz gemütlich ist wochen in
die hier in köln verbringen sitzen uns
das erste mal gemütlich nieder werden
von trillerpfeifen den leighton
überfallen geht überhaupt
aber die feuchtfröhliche männerrunde
können sich bald wieder freuen
die kundgebung ist beendet wäre ich
bereit noch einen jungen kollegen der
ganz am anfang seiner zehn fahrer
karriere steht ihre streiche macht erst
am wochenende von deiner frau und am
wochenende sehe ich erst einmal was hat
er über die woche überhaupt gelernt hat
dass ich endlich wochenende
das ist das ist sage ich mal anders da
kann man es nicht ausdrücken
und für alle dinge geehrt die partnerin
die zu der studie ist mit macht dass das
schwierig heutzutage
[Musik]
schon eine stunde bevor er weiterfahren
darf hat er sich den wecker gestellt
drei der autotransporter hat auf der
einfädelspur übernachtet er muss schnell
weg kommen hat nur noch einen gedanken
im kopf
meine tochter war ich nach hause komme
ich dahin komme zuzudrücken
vielleicht schaffe ich es noch pünktlich
an weniger nicht versuchen kann man es
ja noch aber die wartezeit der letzten
tage hat und nicht müssen aber probieren
möchte ich eigentlich wollte er vor der
operation und seiner tochter schon da
sind
das wird er wohl nicht schaffen jetzt
will er wenigstens dann bei ihr sein
wenn sie aus der narkose aufwacht durch
die alpen geht alles glatt doch kaum hat
er die deutsche grenze hinter sich schon
wieder ein langer stau
also der plan mit dem heute abend und
krankenhäuser der wird wohl nicht auf
jeden irgendwann passiert immer ist
gerade wenn und erwischte das nichts von
zu hause bis zu fünf nicht da die
letzten vorbereitungen vor der operation
in der hamburger kinderklinik darleen
seiner tochter weiß dass ihr vater alles
gibt
[Musik]
gleich geht es los ihre schwere
gehbehinderung soll mit einem
komplizierten eingriff gelindert werden
[Musik]
zurück auf der autobahn ein schwerer
lkw-unfall
mai ist in setzt ein schlimmer anblick
offenbar ist der lkw beladen mit
tonnenschweren papierrollen in die
leitplanken gerast
[Musik]
waren
glaubt die ursache zu erkennen
reifenplatzer konnte sehen dass falls
die neue serie vorne der reifen platzt
du hast du nicht unbedingt drüber
nachdenken
doch dann gibt er wieder gas um schnell
zu seiner tochter zu kommen
[Musik]
brandenburg polizeihauptmeister werner
beinhart hält ausschau mit ihrem alltag
fahrzeug stellen sie verkehrssünder auf
der a12 auf der gesamten a 12 zwischen
frankfurt oder und berlin heißt
überholverbot für lkw
schnell ein zusätzliches beweisfoto aus
der hand damit keiner leugnen kann
nach dem nächsten rastplatz ist ihr dran
nicht nur wegen seiner wilden gefahr sie
entdecken auch noch eine ungesicherte
gasflasche dass kein übel ausgehen
zwar in der festlich stehen aber
trotzdem die es ja nicht richtig
gesichert wie jetzt hoch dagegen schlägt
irgendwie kaputt und das gas tritt frei
ein unfall
all das kostet den fahrer einen halben
monatslohn strafe aber die beamten einen
eher wird es wieder riskieren
aus angst wir stehen immer unter
zeitdruck und dem stress dazu noch das
dauernde verkehrschaos
deshalb passiert so was ein
wissenschaftler hat mal gesagt dass das
herz eines lkw-fahrers 17 jahre älter
ist als ein biologisches alter dh wenn
ich jetzt 29 bin ist mein herz 47 jahre
alt was so alt wie von einem 50 jahre
alten mann
jung studiert unter druck
dahlien wird betäubt k s tochter steht
nun eine lange operation bevor ich hier
oben machen sich bereit für den eingriff
[Musik]
berlin wird während der geburt an
sauerstoffmangel
das führte zu missbildungen an beinen
und hüften
jetzt soll die knochen und kniegelenke
gestärkt werden
darlehens vater kai ist erst im norden
bayerns er weiß jetzt mit seinem
autotransporter wird er es heute nicht
mehr schaffen
er beschließt einen fahrzeugwechsel will
unbedingt beim aufwachen tag sein
damit waren wir gekriegt gut aber
richtung krankenhaus
[Musik]
irgendwo in einem kleinen dorf hinter
coburg kann er seinen truck samt
wertvoller fracht auf einem bauernhof
abstellen der mietwagen ist schon da
eigentlich nicht mal mehr eine
verschnaufpause
er hat noch fast 600 kilometer vor sich
bis in die hamburger kinderklinik ein
heißer ritt aber er kann es schaffen
[Musik]
17.000 liter mineralwasser statt
papierrollen erich ist mal wieder
ausgebrochen aus dem geregelten rentner
leben zurück auf dem bock
er fährt diesmal aber keine
urlaubsvertretung erich hat sich etwas
ganz neues ausgedacht
gemeinsam mit einem kollegen sammelt er
spenden für flüchtlinge aus syrien
afghanistan und afrika
zwei große getränkehersteller
unterstützen sie dabei auch wenn sie
manchmal brauchen wasser ragen und ihr
leben riskiert
getränke im heißen sommer darum hatte
das rote kreuz gebeten
er rief erfolgt die flüchtlingskrise
schon länger er hat das gefühl helfen zu
müssen
das für mich absolutes neuland für
andere leute betteln zu gehen und auch
deine leute zeigen ihr seid nicht allein
hier er seit unserer gäste und das ist
eigentlich mein haupt bewegt etwas was
wir eingestellt
deutlich machen will
erich hat doppelt freude erstens wieder
auf dem bock zweitens auch noch helfen
das rentnerleben mit der frau muss
werden erich zu hause in der preis
einkaufen mit ehefrau chips werden
genehmigt aber gleich zwei packungen
[Musik]
ich mache nichts richtig nur gerne
kritik und forschung mal nichts richtig
vom alleinherrscher zum knecht erich ist
willig erika streng auch beim putzen man
gewohnt
das ist nichts für mich
erich kommt immer wieder zurück hinters
steuer aushilfsjob oder her in hand wie
hier diese mischung macht sein leben als
teilzeit rentner erträglich alles besser
als haushaltshelfer
da stehe ich lieber auf der autobahn im
stau wie irgendwie irgendwo supermarkt
im haus franco stau
da hat er seine alternative zäher
verkehr mitten im rhein main gebiet seit
fünf stunden liegt berlin die tochter
von kai jetzt schon unter dem messer
die op ist aufwendig scheint aber gut zu
verlaufen worden und es hat alles gut
geklappt gab gar keine probleme die
kniegelenke sehen gerade spitz hat es ja
auch nicht mehr
und jetzt nehmen wir noch fertig zu und
machen verband und dann kommt noch
jemand ein auto bild die techniker der
macht noch abdrücke für orthesen und
dann casino berlin auf rang drei hat
glück gehabt kein stroh wenig baustellen
er ist bis hamburg gut durchgekommen
fünf stunden vollgas nach einer
anstrengenden woche
er hat alles gegeben
[Musik]
da ist hin und hergerissen er freut sich
dass er gleich bei seiner tochter ist
und er fühlt sich schuldig weil er nicht
gestern schon da war
seit 20 minuten ist sie im aufwachraum
ihre mutter kreis ex frau ist sichtlich
mitgenommen
[Musik]
langsam kommt darin zu sich friert und
wimmert die betäubung lässt nach
[Musik]
es war ein schwerer eingriff aber
gehofft dass tallinn dadurch bald besser
laufen kann
[Musik]
und dann kann auch kai seine tränen
nicht mehr zurückhalten
[Musik]
im moment laufen und die momente und
wenn doch absolut ja kaum zu hause und
gerade im moment nicht
jetzt haben
hd der schwerlast fahrer ist schon
wieder unterwegs mit anlagenteilen die
nacht beginnt mit einer hiobsbotschaft
eigentlich wollte er dieses wochenende
seinen hochzeitstag verkannt habe gerade
hatte er erfahren dass sich sein
dienstplan verschiebt
aber liegt
heute ist
warten
[Musik]
der scheiße
einen tisch reserviert ein babysitter
organisiert und jetzt das der frust muss
erstmal verarbeitet werden
auf dem rastplatz von hardy den herd 1
meißen mit den kollegen was essen
[Musik]
morgens in deutschland wir machen jetzt
besser halbe stunde pause mikrowelle
futter dauert viereinhalb minuten
zweimal also neun minuten bisschen
abkühlen lassen
kriegen wir hin frisch aus der dose in
die raststätte nebenan wollen sie nicht
beim essen regen sie sich immer noch auf
der neue zeitplan wirft alles
durcheinander
sie können nicht wie üblich am freitag
sondern erst am samstag auf der
baustelle abladen
alle pläne fürs wochenende im 1
die leidtragenden meiner frau berichtet
hatte
leider können wir selber und auch
speiser war das so ist der honig kann
ist aus meiner haut
für polizeihauptmeister weinlage und
seinen kollegen beginnt der tag mit
einem spezialauftrag die brandenburger
beamten nehmen tiertransporte ins visier
ein stück in die stube also bisher rom
an der haustür
die tiere wirken apathisch einen
durchfall zu haben
kollege ralf rick braucht nur einen
kurzen blick in den laderaum umzusehen
der transporter ist für rinder nicht
ausgelegt die tiere drängen sich auf
engstem raum ohne streu stehen sie auf
zwei ebenen in ihrem eigenen dreck
[Musik]
auch mit der höhe des anhängers ist das
nicht in ordnung
[Musik]
der inder personentransport in der menge
nicht reichen na ja es sind verstoßen
tierschutzverordnung wenn er jetzt die
vier meter 1
weil die denn so stehen dann passt sind
mit der tierschutz transport verordnung
aber er versteht es die
straßenverkehrsordnung sowie hat macht
er weiß der fahrer müsste die tiere
eigentlich sofort in ein anderes
fahrzeug umgeladen
aber das würde zu lange dauern die
rinder würden noch länger in der
sengenden hitze leiden
auch weil das ziel nahe ist lassen die
polizisten in ausnahmsweise erfahren
meldungen ans veterinäramt die firma
wird wohl kaum ungeschoren davonkommen
aber bei 10.000 lkw täglich macht sich
polizeihauptmeister werner weinlage auch
keine illusionen über den effekt seiner
arbeit
wenn ich ehrlich bin ich sehe mich dass
wir tropfen auf dem heißen stein mehr
nicht mehr sehe ich da nicht meine meine
augen hier da kontrolldruck nicht hoch
genug ist
ich sehe was mir jeden tag feststellen
und wir unsere kontroll profis und was
dann jeden tag wollen uns vorbei führt
was nie kontrolliert wird sie sind gerne
polizistin aber manchmal fühlen sie
sicher verlorenem posten
[Musik]
samstagfrüh dies truck in der
warteschlange
es dauert ewig bis sie einen platz für
seine ladung haben er seinen laster
darunter wegziehen kann
der boden gibt immer wieder nach die
hinterreifen müssen extra gelenkt werden
per fernbedienung
erst jetzt kann er zusammen bauen für
die heimfahrt
er trauert um sein verpatztes wochenende
aber da hatten wir uns ja ausgemacht
dass wir dieses wochenende schön essen
gehen wollen normalen brauchen ländern
freie wochenende haben ohne kinder waren
für ein paar stunden mal abschalten nur
wir beide wollten zeit ist viel zu wenig
hd baut auf normalen länge zurück
gar nicht so einfach er muss es fast
alleine machen
sein begleiter ist den urlaub aber dann
mit kraft und schmackes geht noch
adi beschließt bis 15 uhr durchzufahren
länger dafür samstags nicht
er hat einen plan auf einem rastplatz
den aufleger abkoppeln
um dann mit der zugmaschine allein doch
noch zum hochzeitstag nach hause zu
kommen ist geladen
da absolut nicht links bis frei
jetzt erst recht in seine frau
überrasche 11 uhr noch 400 km bis
brandenburg
aber es gibt ein problem
[Musik]
paradies schwerlaster bläst rauchwolken
in die luft geht nicht nach abgasen aus
hardy muss anhalten
auf der einfädelspur die autos rasen
einen meter an ihm vorbei
ungerührt bückt er sich in die radläufe
folge fallen
er vermutet einen bremsdefekt hat aber
immer noch keine ahnung was da genau los
ist
schnell weiter weg von hier
bevor doch noch was passiert vorsichtig
fädelt er ein aber von medien entwarnung
sofort klemmt es weiter bis zum nächsten
parkplatz sind es noch 10 kilometer
hardy schleicht im schneckentempo
dorthin
das problem ist gravierender als ihm
lieb ist
[Musik]
die hat sich eine bremsbacken
verabschiedet hier drin
die bremse fest
hier bremst und wahrscheinlich ist
wahrscheinlich bremse abgerissen hier
jetzt mehr lose also die hat sich
verhakt
aber jetzt muss ja die kaputten reifen
wechseln und die bremsen spielen
das wird stunden dauern das ende seiner
pläne nicht mal mehr die überraschung
ist drin
als zehn meter neben der autobahn
herrlicher sonnenschein
270 kilometer vor der heimat einstellen
hochzeitstag im niemandsland wäre ich
altmüller der termin trucker aus der
pfalz noch immer ist er mit seinen
spenden unterwegs gestern war ja in
dresden heute kommt er in marburg an
gar nicht so einfach den eingang zum
flüchtlingslager zu finden
er steht schon mal wiederkommen
ob die jungs morgen mit welt kommt
sie haben jede menge wasser dabei und
popcorn für die kinder
die sicherheitsmaßnahmen sind streng
dieses lager ist ganz neu eingerichtet
ist halb belegt mehrere hundert
schutzsuchende werden im laufe der woche
noch dazukommen
[Musik]
im neu organisieren sich die flüchtlinge
zu einer menschenkette 10.000 liter
wasser wollen erst einmal abgeladen
seien zwei stunden harte arbeit
erich wird unverhofft noch mal zum opa
ich kann das gefühl als glücksgefühl
beschreibe das ist das gefühl etwas
geschafft zu haben was vorher in meinem
ganzen leben ohne körper ab die jungen
männer kommen ordentlich ins schwitzen
ihre ist voll und ganz mit der
kinderbetreuung ausgelastet
[Musik]
auf der popcorn stand kommt an opa erich
ist fasziniert von der kindlichen freude
die hände entgegen
du musst die unbeschreiblich kann man
nicht beschreiben wie man noch eine
popcorn tüte dafür stehen sie
stundenlang an
sciacca erich schließt neue
freundschaften
ich hoffe dass die träne weg bleibe zwar
das ich bin wirklich bin so gerührt und
so emotional das ist wirklich also das
erlebnis das möchte ich nie wieder was
[Musik]
erich der teilzeit rentner zwischen
alltagstrott und autobahnen scheint
seine aufgabe gefunden zu haben
auch im haushalt hat er sich gemacht und
vor neuen vahr aufträgen kann er sich
kaum retten
[Musik]
kai hat sich mittlerweile an den neuen
lkw gewöhnt seiner tochter geht es
inzwischen wieder richtig gut
alle beide lkw gehen und nicht machst du
nicht an die hat es zwischendurch
tatsächlich mal wieder nach hause
geschafft
aber auch dieses wochenende verging
wieder wie im flug
[Musik]